a new report out this morning says some
popular fruit juices may contain heavy
metal contaminants Consumer Reports
tested 45 packaged fruit juices for
heavy metals like a lead arsenic and
caddy cadmium it found measurable levels
in every product long-term exposure to
these metals could cause some serious
health risks like kidney disease and
certain types of cancer more than 80% of
parents with children three years old
and younger give their kids fruit juices
and werner looks at what parents should
do and a good morning
well good morning heavy metals are
substances that make their way into food
because they occur naturally in the air
water and soil they can also wind up in
food during the manufacturing and
packaging processes now Consumer Reports
says improvements have been made since
they last tested juice products eight
years ago but they're still recommending
that parents give their children less
juice as a mom how do you think about
fruit juice so it's the bane of my
existence sure can use your fork mom
Stephanie trilling so she tries hard to
keep her four-year-old daughter away
from juice mostly because of its sugar
content I'll be at a birthday party and
I'll see it on the table and I'll cringe
a little inside because it's not
something I want to give to my kids but
I also don't want to be that mom who's
restricting everything but she may have
another reason to restrict juice intake
a new analysis from Consumer Reports
James dickerson his chief scientific
officer
Consumer Reports wanted to investigate
the state of the juice industry
particularly bottled juice his team
tested 45 different juices for four
heavy metal substances inorganic arsenic
lead cadmium and Mercury
they found that every single product
contained a measurable amount of at
least one heavy metal except for Mercury
21 of the samples contained one or a
combination of heavy metals that reached
a level Consumer Reports researchers
deemed concerning for daily consumption
and Consumer Reports says the metals
found in 7 of the 21 samples had the
potential to harm children who drink
only a half cup per day the CDC says
long-term exposure to
heavy metals may put people at risk for
kidney disease diabetes high blood
pressure damaged ability to learn and
certain types of cancer
Consumer Reports is recommending parents
lower the amount of juice they give
their kids so they should be concerned
but don't panic frequent exposure to
these and heavy metals through the juice
is the concern the juice Products
Association whose Board of Directors
includes executives from PepsiCo Welch's
and other juice brands whose products
were tested said they haven't seen the
full study but called the results
unfounded and told us they're committed
to providing safe and nutritious
products that meet FDA standards they
also said there is no scientific
evidence indicating that trace levels of
heavy metals have caused any negative
health outcomes but dr. Leatrice and a
director of environmental pediatrics at
NYU School of Medicine says science is
telling us increasingly that their
particular time points in life or even a
small amount of exposure and disrupt
hormones and thereby contribute to
disease he recommends parents swap the
juices for something else my suggestion
is that they simply eat an apple
preferably organic and drink water as a
substitute for these juices in 2013 the
FDA proposed limiting inorganic arsenic
and apple juice but no change was ever
made the FDA had no comment Consumer
Reports says their findings are a
spot-check they shouldn't be used to
draw definitive conclusions about any
specific brands and we reached out to
all the juice companies 10 responded
saying their products are safe and
follow all food safety guidelines no
important thing to think about yeah
limiting the amount certainly is good
not only for your health but in limiting
the risk for this yeah a lot of sugar
sometimes do you yeah sure thank you
Anna